hey lady
i got some we've got to reach the
emperor he said he can lead us to
are you certain we have no choice so
before we face him then let us speak
with them
immediately
but lyle has started his attack on the
city let's go ashira is already at the
sewers
hurry we'll keep you safe
the loyal has forced our hand and
started the killing when the fireballs
began falling from the sky we started we
will bring more
the iron wolves will assist i saw people
hiding into the carts
bring them to the sewers we can't risk
our lives on this foolish heroism
we must go to the emperor immediately
we can't let these people die they'll
die
anyway but if we die
watch out keep the people away from
those fireballs
[Music]
we have nowhere to hide
you'll be safe down here there are more
people to the west through the doors
more fuel
i never believed this would end like
this
the light grows
now to the gates we have no time to lose
let's go
so
now leah use your power just the way i
taught you
and bring down these gates stand back
i still can't fully control it
i'm returning to town
the power of hell cannot save you
not enough don't worry about me
thank you
that illusion blocks our past
i need fury
uh
uh
[Music]
not ready
not enough fury
again daughter i feel so weak
i i don't know if i can you must
now
it is up to you now hurry i must stay
here in tentalia praise the gods you've
arrived
just in time show me the soul stone
you'll see it bill isle soon your fetid
soul will be trapped within it clever
one of them
uh
more furious
i will not be ashamed
this world is mine
no way i need fury
of the lord
you're curious
still recharging
uh
quickly leah seal belile soul within the
stone
it is ironic that one as twisted as
zoltan cool played so
great a role in our salvation phil
was once a tireless enemy of hell from
his life
let us learn the longer we fight evil
the more it can corrupt our hearts
i need to go back
today is a good day you have liberated
this land
and brought lo a lord of hell enjoy
this moment for tomorrow our war
continues
there is no time for rest even now
azmodan plots our destruction the lord
of sin
is an uncanny tactician he'll attack us
where he believes we'll least expect it
and where defeat would break our will to
resist
you are learning well leah now you must
go to caldeum's great library
and continue with your uncle's work
i can be ready to leave at a moment's
notice to let me know when you are
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
none of this makes any sense to me
what am i missing
what am i supposed to see
you thought you were so clever
fell into your trap
but not me i defy
you
i know the black soul stone is the key
and it shall be mine
soon my army shall pour forth from the
shattered mountain
ravaging this world and all hope of
resistance
my minions will find the stone
wherever you choose to hide it
then at long last
as modern shall reign as the prime
evil
leah are you all right speak to me
the demon's invasion will come from
caldium is free from belial
and his deception
only as modern remains
he sends his army forth to strike at us
from the heart of ariat crater
bastion's keep is all that stands
between
us and certain doom
i will not allow it
to fall